Hello, and welcome to another episode of Rawkode
Live at the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan, and I am
your host. You may know me as Rawkode
across the Internet.
First, we got a little bit of housekeeping
before we dive into project sigstore supply chain
for Kubernetes containers and other things.
Now the housekeeping involves, first, subscribe into the
channel. If you're not already subscribed to the
Rawkode Academy, please do so now.
Tick the bell, and you will get notifications
and alerts for all new episodes as we
explore the cloud native landscape together.
If you wanna join and chat with other
members of the Rawkode Academy about all things
cloud native, Kubernetes, and everything in between, join
us on the Discord at Rawkode.chat.
And if you want to support this channel,
please take a look at the membership options
options available at the Rawkode Academy on the
YouTube page. You can subscribe for as little
as a single dollar a month and get
loads more cool goodies.
Nailed the intro. Thanks. I'm getting assaulted already
before we even started. Thanks, man.
I do my best. Alright.
Today, we're taking a look at sigstore.
I am not smart enough or wise enough
to guide us through this journey, so I
am going to introduce
Dan Lawrence. Hey, man. How's it going?
Great. How are you? Well,
I mean, I was better until I fluffed
the intro a couple of times, but other
than that, I'm doing pretty well. Can you,
for the audience, if they're not familiar, just
tell us a little bit about you, please?
Sure. Yeah. I'm a software engineering lead at
Google. I work on our open source security
team.
So my job for the past couple of
years has been trying to make it easier
to build open source software securely and make
it easier for Google and all of our
customers to use it securely and not have
to worry about these nasty supply chain attacks
that keep happening in there all over the
news.
Nice.
So we're gonna be taking a look at
sigstore and the multiple components of it today.
Like
so how would you describe the project to
people?
Yeah. It's a good question. So sigstore is
a little complicated of a project. It's got
a bunch of different components and a bunch
of different entry points depending on exactly what
type of software you're trying to build
or consume or anything like that. So we're
gonna start with all of these intros with
the cosign tool. The cosign tool is spelled
c o s I g n, and it's
designed to make signing and verification of container
images really, really easy. Here, we'll start there
because this is a cloud native stream.
Mean, containers and Kubernetes should be pretty familiar
to most people.
All the different components, we'll kind of explain
as we get through them, going through some
of the demos.
But at a high level, the overall goal
for sigstore is to kind of do what
Let's Encrypt did for HTTPS
and certificates,
but for
open source code and signing instead of encryption
and web traffic.
So Let's Encrypt set out a few years
ago to make it easy and free to
get SSL certificates because before that, they were
expensive and hard to get, and so people
weren't doing it. So web traffic was insecure.
They made it free, easy, and automatic, and
now something like 98% of all web traffic
is encrypted because people wanna do the right
thing if it's easy and free. We see
the same thing in open source code and
software supply chains today where there are some
kind of existing code signing systems, but they're
really expensive. It's like $500 to get a
certificate to sign your code to ship it
for different operating systems and platforms.
So most people just don't do it, especially
in large open source projects where, you know,
there's not even a business that could be
verified and that kind of thing behind these
projects.
So we've got a certificate authority that we're
gonna be playing around with today to get
some code signing certificates issued based on your
email address. There's a bunch of different tools
inside of cosign two to assign images with
YubiKeys and KMS systems and Kubernetes secrets and
all that fun stuff. So depending on exactly
how you're getting the image, who's producing it,
who's signing it, we've got tools and flags
and features for all of that here that
we'll be walking through, and then we'll be
explaining how kind of the sigstore infrastructure makes
all of this possible.
Awesome. Quite a lot there. We could probably
dive into. But I think the the first
thing I wanted to see, like, what the
fuck the deal with prices of search ten
years ago? I mean,
I remember working for sorry. Don't mean to
swear. It's only afternoon here. But I
remember working, you know, ten years ago, even
longer, and you had to go buy all
of these search, and they were, like, $500
plus if you went with a reputable company
to get your website delivered over SSL as
it was back then. But
and now it's just something that if anyone
new to development has less encrypt available, it's
just an absolute game changer. So it's really
cool.
I won't complain about I I won't run
about EV certs either. I'll leave that for
another day. But
And, actually, the EV certs are the super
expensive ones. That's kinda what you need to
get for doing code signing today. So it's
it's really bad. Yeah. But
we are talking about supply chain. Right? And
that's one of the I I think we've
seen that a lot over the last twelve
months. I mean, how many supply chain checks
I mean, I only know what I've seen
in the news, which is probably the more
high profile one. But I'm assuming you may
have more visibility into what's actually going on
in the ecosystem right now. Like, this is
a really prominent problem. Right?
Yeah. They've they've been happening for years.
They've been accelerating,
I think, for a couple reasons. Open source
is getting more and more widely used, which
is great for open source, but more companies
are using it.
Not all open source has a lot of
people working on it, a lot of people
looking at it, unfortunately. There's kind of this
misconception that if it's on GitHub and the
project has a bunch of stars, then there
are gonna be no bugs inside of it.
As maintainer of a bunch of projects with
a bunch of GitHub stars, I can tell
you that's incorrect. All of my code has
bugs. All of the code you're using has
bugs in it. And so, yeah, the the
supply chain attacks either through, you know, bugs
that are put in unintentionally or the scarier
ones where people kind of take over GitHub
accounts. They steal credentials to container registries
are are coming. They're coming quick.
Thankfully, there are actually some huge ones over
late
last week over the weekend that thankfully were
a researcher who reported them rather than an
attacker.
But somebody threw some misconfigured GitHub actions,
managed to get write permissions to the entire
PyPy package index. Oh, damn. Could've tampered with
change any of those packages in there. They're
not really signed today, so nobody would have
known. Thankfully, he reported it and got these
issues fixed, got the GitHub actions locked down
a little bit, but that would have been
a really, really scary one.
There's a similar one. I think it was
even the same person actually with Microsoft Versus
Code's GitHub repository.
Got write permissions to branches there that would
have triggered releases and pushed out, you know,
malicious versions of Versus Code.
Anybody that's kind of thinking about this and
paying attention now would realize how terrifying and
scary that would be if somebody compromised the
IDE that 99%
of other developers use, you know, what kind
of backdoor can they get put into all
the code build? That's why I only had
a code with said. So you know?
I just write it on a piece of
paper and hand it to somebody else.
Nice.
Alright. That was terrifying. There's now been, you
know, executive orders in The United States to
help start locking a lot of this stuff
down and securing it because governments are getting
hit with ransomware.
A lot of scary things.
Yeah. It is very scary.
And sigstore and its components
help alleviate a lot of these concerns. Is
that is that the best way to describe
it?
Good idea. Yeah. I think when we talk
about open source security,
there are kind of two high level problems
that I think are orthogonal. They're they're different,
and we've got to address both of them.
The first one is that all the code
is
open source,
which is great, but it means, you know,
anybody's writing it, anybody's working on it. You
might not have any idea who the maintainers
are.
That's pretty cool in some ways, but it's
also scary because anybody that spent time on
the Internet knows that not everybody on the
Internet is a nice person. So you're taking
code from, you know, potentially bad people and
running it.
Even worse, you don't even know where the
code is coming from for the most part.
If your Docker pulls some container, you have
no idea where that came from. If the
code even actually came from the repo, will
it it's paired to the, you know, Docker
registry or anything.
And so that's kind of around transparency and
not actually understanding what our supply chains are.
And that's the angle we're trying to address
with sigstore. So if you've got a container,
you can figure out exactly how it was
built, what code went into it,
what build steps were run, that kind of
thing.
That doesn't make it secure. It just means
you understand the supply chain. That's kind of
the first step in securing your supply chain.
There could still be malware checked into that
GitHub repo. But today, you can't even find
the GitHub repo to look for malware in
most of these cases.
So the second half of open source software
and security is that it's software, it has
bugs, some intentional, some unintentional.
So sigstore isn't gonna secure everything completely. Right?
There could still be bugs. There could still
be CVEs, but at least we're hoping to
give you the tools to understand what versions
of code you're running, where it came from,
that kind of thing. So you can start
addressing that second problem.
Okay. Let me try and phrase this in
my own words so I kind of understand
Sure. Where sigstore can fit. Right? But I
like to think of it as the problem.
Like, we all consume open source code in
our projects. And what we can do is
we can audit the code that we use
and never update it, which is usually the
enterprise approach. Right? Or we can always be
pulling in the latest one and trying to
avoid all those security conflicts, and there's very
little in the middle. Does sigstore help us
bridge these two different approaches and have more
confidence and frequently updating our packages and our
dependencies?
That's a really, really good way to put
it. Yeah. And it that's controversial, it comes
up a lot about, you know, that strategy
of how often should I be updating and
that kind of thing.
I'm on the the opinion that, yeah, you've
gotta be updating frequently.
It does put you at risk. In some
cases, it's a lot of work. It's tough,
but I think you just have to be
doing these updates. Otherwise,
you're behind.
You're gonna get hit with these CVs that
are found years later, and and you can
get yourself into a position where you've got
years of code to try to update all
at the same time, which is really tough.
It's it's really bad. It's embarrassing when you
get hit with one of those two.
Forgot to update struts that's been running here,
and now everybody's credit card data's been leaked,
that kind of thing. So I think you've
gotta get to a point where you can
be updating frequently. You know, shift it left
if you wanna use buzzwords. Update your dependencies
as often as possible with stuff like Dependabot.
And then the scary part there is, you
know, the whole wall, it wasn't broken. Why
would I fix it? Now I'm, you know,
putting myself at a bigger risk, pulling in
all these new changes constantly.
And that's where since we're we're hoping to
make that easier and safer and less scary
to do by making it you confident, basically,
in all the code you're pulling in constantly,
knowing where it came from. Nice. Well, easier
and less scary sounds good to me. So
why don't we dive in and get started
then?
Let me pop up my screen share. We're
still here. We've got the sigstore website here.
You suggested that we're gonna start by taking
a look at the cosign project first
to play around with some container image scanning.
So we'll do that right away. To the
people that are watching, thank you for all
the comments so far. If you have any
questions for Dan, feel free to drop them
in the chat. We'll do our best to
tackle them as we go.
Alright. Step one,
cosign.
This is
container signing, verification, and storage, and an OCI
registry. You wanna break that down for us
a little bit?
Sure. Yeah. So what Incosign lets you do
is yeah. Just kinda stay right there. You
can sign container images that you built.
You can verify those,
signatures,
and everything for it is stored in an
OCI registry. You don't need to run any
extra services.
This all just works with any Docker registry
you're gonna be playing around with today.
There's a quick little demo that, you know,
kinda scrolls there showing the simplest way, but
there's about 37 different ways to kinda generate
and manage the keys that we're gonna be
using for signing stuff here. This is the
simplest one. It just kinda throws one in
a file on your disk. So that's probably
the one we should start out with if
you wanna give it a try. But we've
got some other cool ones that I'll show
you once you get cosign set up and
get some stuff signing.
Okay. So I guess my step one is
to install the cosign
application.
Yeah. We do have a we just got
a brew release.
Maybe it didn't make it into the docs
yet. So if you've got go, you could
go install. That might take a little while
or you can just do brew install cosign.
It should work.
Yeah. I'm happy with the brew install approach.
Let me just drag the bottom of this
window.
Oh, maybe it says it's on tap.
Yeah. I'm just forgetting how this works.
Here we go.
Is there a tap repository
on sigstore?
Yeah. Cosign
and wait.
Tap.
And I can always pull down the banner.
Right? But if we know the
brew
What is it called?
Homebrew
tap. There we go.
Yep. Brew tap
sigstore
slash tap. Here we go.
And then brew install goes in.
You can do it all on one command.
I learned this, like, last week, and I'm
just obsessed with doing it on one command.
Oh, nice.
So, actually, there's a really cool little
history I'll show while this is downloading.
Yeah. Okay. So this just downloads directly from
our repo. But at some point over the
last year, Homebrew switched
the packages that are stored in, you know,
their default Homebrew
repo
Yeah. From
something I can't remember what it was, but
they switched it over to GHCR.
Yep. So the GitHub Container Registry.
So Homebrew uses an OCI registry to store
all of the binaries for Mac stuff just
because it's free and it's everywhere and it's
really easy to put stuff in it. So
these aren't containers you're installing at Homebrew for
the most part, but they're just kind of
hijacking and using OCI registries anyway, which is
cool.
Yeah. I've I've noticed that with a lot
of brew packages coming from g
GHCR.
It's really cool the way they're using the
OCI format there for that, definitely. But I
think because this is your own tap,
you would have to upload to that yourself
rather than anything else.
So we've got a couple of comments already.
So Kevin the Fireflash
saying it looks really similar to how RPM
works.
I'm
not sure how RPM works myself, but I'll
trust your take your judgment there.
Kelly Jack was telling me to use Nix.
I can't because I stupidly upgraded to the
Mac OS beta and now nothing works except
my streaming software. So
stay tuned for lots more. Sorry.
There's a next formula or whatever it's called
for cosine too. I got it running in
a container, which is awesome. Sweet.
And there's a a first question there for
you. So is cosine admission controller going to
be adopted into sext or or stay in
your personal GitHub?
Good question. Yeah. So it's probably referring to
I have a little toy admission controller I
was I wrote to just kinda learn how
builder and the new admission controller stuff, the
SDK is all put work together.
I called it cosigned, c o s I
g n e d, to check the make
sure everything is resigned.
I,
you know, didn't write tests. The code barely
works. I I stuck it up there. Didn't
wanna put it into the real sigstore thing.
I wasn't sure if people would use it
if it was worth spending more time on.
But then people started filing bugs, of course,
which happens with open source and running in
production and all that scary stuff. I gotta
figure out if I wanna take it down
or actually move it over into the org.
There's some other policy engines now that are
adding support, so I don't know how much
we're gonna keep needing mine.
Stuff like and gatekeeper
and other support
for cosign signatures.
Yeah. It doesn't matter how much you put
a warning in the read me saying, do
not use this. People are quick because it's
got to use a net to solve the
problem. They wanna get it in the product
and fix that. Yeah.
Yeah. So it's there.
I don't have a perfect answer. Sorry about
that.
Alright.
So we got cosign CLI. Do you want
me to jump back over to the repo
and type in that command? Are we just
gonna
tap complete through it? Live from here. Yeah.
Yeah. So actually, real quick first. Do you
have a container we can work with? Do
have a container set up in some registry
somewhere? It doesn't have to be super
Hey. Yeah. I've I've I've got the clustered
demo application, which we could sign, which runs
which is stored on GHCR.
So is that that work? Perfect. Yeah. As
long as you get right permissions set up
for that, that should be perfect. Alright.
So, yeah, let's we'll start by generating a
key pair. So you can just type generate
hyphen key hyphen pair.
Try out the hyphens right now. Should I
spend docker up just now, actually?
Nope. Nothing docker. Okay.
Alright. So generate key pair.
Got a whole bunch of options.
We're just doing it vanilla, so it's gonna
generate a private key for us. Is that
correct?
Yep. And you can type you should type
in a password.
Should or must? I
don't I don't remember what happens if you
just hit enter, but
hopefully, it'll match.
Yeah. There we go. Cool.
Alright. So now you've got two new files
on disk here, which I'll explain quickly and
we can show to people.
This uses Cosign uses digital signatures,
which means you get two different keys. There's
a public key and a private key. The
public key is the one you publish.
You distribute that one widely. Anybody who wants
to check your images can check the signatures
against that public key. So if you just
wanna cap that, we can see what it
looks like.
Cool. Yep. So that this is the public
key. That's it. It uses
elliptic curve cryptography if you're into that and
some details here. But, yeah, we picked
some good defaults. There are no real flags
here. We only support a couple different algorithm
combinations and stuff like that. That's the public
key. It's pretty small. That's the thing you
have to publish and send around to let
people check against.
Now let's take a look at the secret
key too. So I said this is secret,
but it's encrypted with that password. So it's
actually okay to show as long as you
don't tell us the password too.
So says begin encrypted cosign private key. So
nobody can do anything with this unless they
also have your password. So hopefully, it's not
just
Rawkode one or something like that. No. It's
a b c one two three.
Perfect. Yeah. Hunter one two or whatever it
is. Hunter two. Yeah. That's the Yeah. Everybody
type your type your passwords into the chat
here.
Yeah. So that's the that's the one we're
gonna be using to sign stuff with.
So we are ready to go now with
these two files.
Now you can sign your container image. Cool.
So If you remember the URL, you just
do cosign sign. Oh, it's saying. I was
just making it out. Right? Okay. Oh, yep.
That's right, though.
Yeah. There's bunch of different flags here. As
you can see at the top, we support,
like, all the different cloud providers have a
KMS system that you can use so you
don't have to have the keys locally if
you wanna use that stuff. HashiCorp Vault has
that too.
But if you've got the file, you can
just do dash key and pass in the
cosign dot key the secret key,
and then the name of the image you
wanna assign. So the g h c r
clustered thing.
We'll send we'll send you to it. Why
not? You've
gotta remember the password.
So you're not authenticated. You might have to
refresh or do something there.
I should have g h.
Let's see. I'll log in.
I'm already logged in. I wonder if I
need to do something.
Your
g h c r.
When in doubt, Google it.
Login.
Yeah. I don't think I've ever actually tried
g h c r from my laptop. I
know they give you those tokens automatically from
inside of Git Hub actions.
Yeah. I just assumed because I use the
GitHub CLI
that it would
oh, you just use a personal access token.
But how would that work with cosign?
It'll it'll figure it all out.
Yeah. You do the Docker login or whatever.
Alright. Okay. So let's And cosign, it'll just
work once you do that. Okay. So there's
Docker spinning up. I'm gonna create a personal
access token and then I'll log in.
I'll do that over here.
Set up flashing credentials on this stream.
Perfect.
So I'm assuming you would not encourage people
to use
the the way that we generated the key
and instead to use, like, a cloud KMS
provider or something. Right?
It depends what you have access to and
what you're trying to convey,
I guess. There are bunch of different, you
know, reasons to sign things, and it's but
there's a lot of confusion around exactly what
you're trying to express with the signature.
Really, at the at the base level, all
it means is that whoever had access to
that private key
signed the thing. It doesn't mean it's good.
It doesn't mean it's safe. It just means
that they use the private key to sign
the thing.
And so if you wanna keep it locally
and you're sure you can protect it and
not lose that password, that's a fine approach.
You can also use something like a YubiKey.
There are some commands for that if you've
got one instead, which means that people can't
steal that from you unless they actually take
the token, so you don't have to worry
about losing it.
The KMS stuff is great if you're in
a cloud environment. It's better than storing the
password somewhere else in the secret manager or
that kind of thing.
But there's some downsides there too, which is,
like, you know, many times have people screwed
up IAM on their AWS cluster or, you
know, their GCP environment or whatever. You're kind
of trading off
not having to lose the key with making
sure that you get the IAM and the
RBAC and all those roles right so that,
you know, you don't make it too broad
so people can start using the key.
So there's some some trade offs either way.
Alright. I'm just doing a Docker login.
Okay.
I'm logged in.
I say that as a question rather than
a statement. But
Yeah. So now it should just work, hopefully.
Well, that seems promising. There we go.
Awesome.
Yeah. So all the credentials that Docker uses
are set up in this kinda global credential
helper file. It's pretty well understood. So most
tools know how to work with that once
you've done the Docker login stuff. Awesome. So
that's signed.
Let's
well,
naturally, we should probably just verify that first
before we move on and jump in and
show exactly what happened.
Yeah. So let's try the other half there.
You can type cosign verify, and then you'll
see all the different options we have here.
Yep. You now you pass in the public
one. Step to private.
I know I picked a different version there.
I just wanted to see
what happened.
Alright.
So it says so first of all, when
I use the version that wasn't signed, we
just get some sort of name unknown. So
it doesn't know that
something in this OCI registry exists a signature.
I'm not sure how those signatures work with
the registry, but maybe it's not important.
When we use a tag that does exist,
we get some checks performed.
So there's closing claims,
the signature matches the key,
and that's the actual version. Right?
Yep. So that's the actual signature that got
stored there at the bottom.
Do you happen to have the crane tool?
There are couple different tools to work with,
kinda debugging registries. If you have that, we
can show exactly how the signatures work and
everything.
The crane with a c, isn't it? Yeah.
C r a n e, like for lifting
containers up and down. Yeah. Familiar of the
tool, but it's not something I keep
at hand. Yeah. It's it's the easiest way
to do some debugging here.
Cool. This is working. Nice.
And it came from
no. It didn't. No. It did.
Yep. It came from GHCR.
Nice.
Okay.
So do we want to
Yeah. So now we've got crane.
We want let's take a look at what
the signature
is
in here. So first, crane.
Actually, there's a fundamental command first. We have
to run do cosign
triangulate.
Oh, some trigonometry comes in here
of the the image name we signed.
So we hide these things inside of the
registry, the signatures. And the way we do
it is with a cool little naming convention,
which
should make sense in a second. So the
image we signed was clustered colon v one
sorry, v two.
And the way a registry works is that
there are tags and digests there for to
an image. The tag is kinda mutable. It's
just a string, but it points to a
fixed SHA two five six digest for that
image that can't move around.
The way we find the
signature for an image is that we take
that digest, the thing that can't move, and
we turn that into a tag and then
tack a little suffix there at the end
of the dot sig. So if we wanna
find the signature for clustered colon v two,
we first resolve that to a digest, and
that's what the cosine triangular command did. And
then we turn that digest into a tag
with a colon instead of the at sha
two five six thing there.
And then we add the dot sig. So
the signature itself,
sorry, is stored in this image. It's not
an image you can docker pull or run.
But just like Homebrew stores other things in
a registry, that's what we do here too.
So if you do crane
manifest and then that thing, this is gonna
download the,
you know, bytes that we've stored in the
registry. Remove the chat 256. Right? No. So
leave that. Just add the dot sig at
the end, actually. Alright. Okay.
Yeah. Cool.
And then if you have j q, you
could pipe it to that so it's more
readable. Cool.
Perfect.
So this looks like a normal Docker image
or an OCI image. You can see it's
got the layers,
except instead of having a
tarball that would unpack into your system,
we just cram a little signature in there
instead.
Except that annotation is, the signature is just
that base 64 encoded string.
The MEQ thing, if you take that and
look at it, it's just, you know, random
bytes that were generated by the
signing algorithm.
And then the layer itself is a blob.
You can see the digest for it. And
that is the little payload we signed. So
when we did verify up above, we got
that JSON that spit out on that last
line. That is the thing we signed.
So we store the signature and then the
little thing we signed here in the registry.
That's how that all works. So the verify
step,
when you typed in the wrong tag, gave
you that error saying it couldn't find a
signature.
So that's what that was. It was looking
in this location for an image. Couldn't find
it.
But then we did find it, downloaded this
thing, checked all of it, and it was
good.
There are a couple other little features we
can show here with sign and verify
if you wanna see.
The first one is you can add in
little random key value pairs when you sign,
and you can check those too.
So if you go back to your sign
command, you can add in dash a and
just make up a little
probably have to put it before the image
name because that's just a positional.
Yeah. Perfect. You just do foo equals bar,
whatever you wanna do. You could put in
a git commit. You could put in a
release version here. You could put in
anything kind of more meaningful than just signing
the image itself. You could say LGTM equals
yes, you know, whatever you wanna do and
just hit enter.
So this is gonna show we can actually
sign images multiple times. So we're gonna have
two signatures on this image now. One doesn't
have any of these annotations. This one will
have the foo equals bar.
Now if you verify again, we should see
both signatures this time, one with it and
one without.
Cool. So you see these two JSON blobs
get spit out, and the second one has
that foo equals bar thing.
Nice. When you verify now, pretend you wanna,
you know, only check things with foo equals
bar, you can add that into the dash
a, and it'll only show you ones with
that matching thing. So people built up, you
know, pretty good workflows with this to sign
specific releases and then check
specific releases,
or you can put in container vulnerability scans
or anything else you kinda wanna write up
in your policy engine.
I'm curious. Right? Like, this this is a
random image that I pushed to a registry
in the past, but, I mean, I have
no idea really if that is even still
my image. Like, what would be the actual
workflow that we would encourage people to use
with cosignation?
Should they build it, sign it, and then
push it to the registry, or do they
build it, push it to the registry, and
then sign it? Like, what do you recommend
there?
Yeah. So there there's a couple different workflows
that make that make sense here.
The
first one is trying to make sure that
the image came from the source and was
built the right way.
And so the best thing to do there
is to sign it in your build system,
like, as close as possible to when it
was built.
Your build system usually knows the digest of
the image, and so you just have the
build system sign in at the same time.
So if your build system gets hacked or
something like that, you're not really protected. But
as soon as it leaves that build system,
you at least know that that image is
the same one that left the build system.
There's a GitHub action that we have, the
cosign installer that throws it into a GitHub
action if you can use that. And then
because GitHub actions gives you those cool personal
access tokens, then you don't even need to
set up auth or anything like that if
you're pushing and signing stuff in GHCR.
Depending on your build system, you can plug
in other stuff.
Tekton
CD is a Kubernetes native c I c
d platform that actually has built in support
now where you can just kinda say sign
all the images that get built with this
directly from the build system.
So to
kinda protect against that, making sure that the
thing is actually what was built, signing it
in the build system is the best way
to do it.
Some other companies in, you know, kinda regulated
industries and financial stuff and health care need
to make sure that, you know, two people
have approved each change that goes to prod.
So it's kind of a different flow. And
a lot of people there use, like, two
different YubiKeys, and two different people have to
sign the image as the very last step.
So that's kind of like it's been built.
It's been tested. It's been in our QA
environment for a while. Now we have to
have two out of these, you know, seven
people
sign it with their own Yuba keys as
the last step. So you can kinda build
up workflows with, you know, different levels of
signatures coming from different places. There's no real
one size
fits all approach. But I think for most
people, they want that first one of just
signing the stuff that left their build system.
Alright. Perfect.
We've got a few questions if you're happy
for me to Yeah. Look for them now.
Sure.
So let's see.
I think we may be covered the first
one here. O six says,
how is signing done in automation?
Do you put no password, or is the
position that real humans should sign releases?
Yeah. So that's that's the one we kinda
just talked about. I've got a little demo
app called, like, sign container on GitHub. It
shows how to do it in GitHub actions
where you don't really need the password. You
can kinda use it. And then there are
even some different flows we'll get to next
Okay. Using things like
OIDC
and different protocols to sign things inside of
a build system. So, yeah, I think humans
and systems should sign it, not one or
the other, I guess.
Okay.
Next question is, does the token have permission
or I guess, does the token that we
use need to have permission to push to
GHCR?
Yeah. That's another good question. With this flow,
what we did is we stored the signatures
right in the same repository as the image,
so literally right next to them when we
did the triangular command.
So, yeah, you need that permissions to push
to that one.
That doesn't work for some people where they
don't want their developers to have permissions to
these registries, only their build systems. So there
are some flags to kinda redirect and store
them in a different one. So it still
uses that same naming convention, except instead of,
you know, g h c r slash raw
code, it would be something like g h
c r slash raw code signatures.
You would say, I'm gonna store all my
signatures here
so my devs can push to there, but
not to the,
you know, bucket where the containers themselves are
stored. Okay.
Am I correct in thinking that cosign executable
needs to be built with the YubiKey feature
enabled?
Yeah. Another good question. The YubiKey stuff, depending
on your OS and your platform, sometimes needs
some native c libraries to actually work correctly
with the drivers.
On Mac and Windows, I believe it just
kinda works.
There are some go build tags
for Linux where you do need to have
some special dependencies installed.
It doesn't run by default on stuff like
Alpine, so we publish two different builds for
Linux. If you're not gonna use the EBAQ
one, you can just do a native Go
build with no CEO. But if you want
that, then you've gotta use the CEO version,
which is a little harder to cross compile.
Alright. One more question, and then we'll carry
on. Asks,
what does triangulate do with multiple signatures? I'm
guessing it provides them all.
Yeah. So we actually store all the signatures
in the same
blob. So, yeah, triangulate just points to the
blob thing that has all the signatures. When
we saw the if you do the crane
manifest
again command, we'll see now that there are
gonna be two layers.
The first time, there was just one layer.
Yep. So all the layers just kind of
get appended up into this list.
So it shows you the address for all
of those, and then we kinda go through
and verify them against the key. We did
both of these signatures using the same key,
but you could imagine two different people with
two different keys signing it, and you would
kinda see all of those appended up, and
we'd filter through them as we do verify.
Nice.
Okay. So we have taken a container image.
We have signed it.
Is the next step that we want to
restrict our runtime to only run images that
are signed, or is there something in between?
Yeah. Let's do a couple more things first.
Also, I screwed up trying to get the
policy engine set up this morning, so I'm
stalling a bit too. But
yeah. So let's let's let's show some of
the cooler fancy stuff that'll actually kind of
pivot and explain so that the rest of
sigstore and how that works.
Let's do this is the cool experimental
keyless mode that I like to call it.
We just did some signing with keys, but
now we're gonna be signing without keys.
So we need to turn on the experimental
flag
first. I don't why it's experimental still in
a minute and all that stuff. But it's
an environment variable. So do export
cosign underscore experimental equals one. Yep. All caps.
Perfect.
Alright.
Now we're gonna do a sign again, except
let's not pass in a key. So just
do cosign sign.
You can leave on the annotations if want.
It doesn't matter. Yep. Just the image now.
No keys. The same image or a different
image?
Up to you. Okay.
That's it? Yep.
Just hit enter. It's magic.
There are no keys. We're gonna we're gonna
see some logs, and now you're
ah, yeah. You're only sharing your terminal. But
what just happened here Sorry. There we go.
Oh, perfect. Yeah. It popped open on browser
window. So we're gonna go through here and
do kind of the the OpenID
dance. And if you see what was back
in the terminal sorry to make you keep
switching.
But what we actually did here is we
generated a key
in memory. This is generating ephemeral keys. And
now this is the CA piece, the certificate
authority thing we were talking about before. So
we're gonna get a certificate
from the sigstore CA tied to the email
address,
whichever email address you click on in that
browser window.
So if you're you're familiar with Let's Encrypt,
the way they do it is they, you
know, give you an automatic certificate by proving
you own a domain name,
and they do that with
Acme challenge thing where they give you a
little token you have to display on the
domain names, so then they're sure you own
it.
We do the same thing here except for
an email address. There's already a bunch of
protocols for that. OpenID Connect is the one
we use here. So we approve you have
that email address, and we give you a
certificate for that email address instead of a
domain name. So whatever the email is on
the GitHub
login you just did will be in a
certificate. So instead of signing with a key
now, we sign with an email address.
So if we do verify now again with
no key,
we will see the signature and the email
address.
Yeah. The
magic keyless mode. David@rawkode.com.
That's the subject of the certificate.
Cool. You got some questions?
Just
that's super cool from Noel and Sean there.
Okay. Cool.
Yeah. So I'll explain kinda what happened there
because there's some magic behind the scenes. It's
kinda subtle to make all of that work,
including that last line, the TLOG entry created
with index line.
So the way this works, if you've heard
of Let's Encrypt and certificate transparency,
we kinda copy that same thing.
All of the certificates that we issue through
the service get logged to a transparency log,
which is a really cool data structure where
it's append only and people can kinda verify
that and check and monitor it. So the
entry there is 33319.
That'll only ever go up. Your certificate is
in
that log. The signature is in that log,
and you can look at it, and it
will never get tampered with. And it will
be there forever the way the Merkle trees
and fancy computer science works.
And so what that lets you is it
protects you against our service getting hacked. Right?
If our service got compromised or hacked, we
could start issuing certificates for your email,
that you didn't request. We could just kind
of bypass the open ID thing, which proves
you requested it. So this lets people monitor
the log for any certificates issued for their
email address. If they see something in there,
they say, hey. I didn't sign a container
that day. They know something bad happened. They
also know the exact container that got signed
too. So it's not just something bad happened.
They know, hey, somebody stole my email account.
They stole my password because I accidentally broadcast
it live on the stream. And they started
assigning containers with my name. And you can
figure out the exact ones that they signed
and tell people not to use those.
So the keys were generated at the top
there in memory. They never touched disk. They
were deleted right after.
And so it'd be pretty hard for somebody
to get those keys,
but there's some other kind of fancy stuff
we do there to protect against that too.
We got another question?
Just another. That's really cool. A
lot of love for this approach, definitely.
Yeah.
So this is a really good way to
do it as a user if you're trying
to sign with an email address.
It's a little harder to set up for
demos here today. But if you're familiar with
projects like Spiffy and Spire,
they use that same protocol, the OpenID Connect
one, to do certificates
and keys for machines.
You set up, you know, nodes and pods
in your cluster with those identities that instead
of an email address, it looks like spiffy
colon slash slash and then some name you
make up for your domain name and then
the machine and everything itself. So those services
can go through the same flow too, where
every time they wanna sign something,
they authenticate with their SPIFI ID, and we
give that machine a certificate. So we can
use that to sign stuff in that short
time window.
So for build systems and everything,
that's if you don't have a fancy HSM
or hardware security module or
KMS system, then this approach works great too
if you're fine with storing these certificates in
a transparency log.
So I've got a, I guess, then a
couple of questions. So Yeah. The first one,
experimental.
Yeah. What is the status of this, and
when is that likely to change and become
generally available?
Out that, you know, transparency logs and immutable
ledgers and storing data in something that can't
be deleted and bring out a lot of,
you know, GDPR and legal and, you know,
what happens if people sneak bad stuff in
there that, you know, we're not allowed to
host and that kind of thing, those risks.
So it's it's good from a code and
a stability standpoint. We're just trying to work
through and get approvals from all of the
lawyers and stuff like that to stand this
up and let that data stay around and
figure out what we would do if something
really, really bad ended up in there. There's
nothing brand new to solve. Right? The certificate
transparency people have been dealing with this for
years. We just gotta get through that. So
we're hoping in the next couple of months,
we can take that off once we figure
out the playbooks for what we do in
some really bad situations.
Okay.
How do I
like,
I've got this index number.
Yeah. Like, how do I check for entries
with my email address and and and things
like that?
Yes. We're gonna have to get another tool
that I don't think is in Brew yet,
but we can download it and build it
and everything like that.
But yeah. So you'll see when you did
that check,
cosigned, did the verification.
Yeah. Existence of the claims and the transparency
log is verified offline. So cosign did it
automatically when we did the verify, but we
can kinda walk through the steps to do
it manually if you wanna get the Recore
tool installed.
See if we have I think we have
proof for this yet.
Your binary is published. It's in a bunch
of different pack parameters, but not brew.
Or you can clone the repo, build it,
or grab the binary yourself, whichever you wanna
do.
The Darwin
Just get in. And the This stuff is
you'll see these binaries are all signed too
with cosign, so that's cool.
Perfect.
And I download.
That's it.
Alright.
So let's let's scroll back up and find
that index that it printed out, and we'll
just grab that one right away.
Yep. Just the number? Cool. Yep.
I do Recore
get dash dash log hyphen index,
I think it is, and pass in that.
Cool. And we'll get a bunch of hard
to read data back out.
So this is the entry for that specific
signature we did in the transparency log.
We store the thing we signed,
the hash of it. So that's the data
hash value thingy.
That's the hash of that JSON object we
signed.
Excuse me. There's that signature there, and then
there's the public key. So that is gonna
be the certificate. So you copy paste out
that long thing.
It's base 64 encoded. You can touch from
the equal sign. So that's my trick.
You should be able to see some more
stuff.
Don't think it copied right. It didn't work.
Yeah.
What's happening?
Yeah. You're losing the equal signs at the
end somehow. Right? It's losing much more than
that. So let's
do that.
Tap in difficult. Try again.
There we go. Okay. So that is the
certificate that we issued for you. If you've
got open SSL, I can never remember the
commands for this.
Open SSL. You can type that to open
SSL
x five zero nine
dash text
dash
maybe that's all you need. Let me see
what happens.
It's a million different OpenSSL versions. There's some
tool that'll show you
maybe
no out. That's another one I have on
here. Oh, sorry. Not dash x 509. Just
x 509. Alright. Okay.
There we go.
Oh, and then do dash text maybe to
stick that on. We'll see So if you
scroll up, you'll see the all the info
in there where everything is stored, the algorithm,
the key, your email address is there too
at the bottom. That's the subject thing.
There you go. Perfect. Yep. So
if you're you can kinda tell this log
there's new entries that come in. You can
just keep grabbing the index and verify it.
And the whole thing only works if people
are doing that, which is nice because people
are. So there are people that constantly verify
our log and make sure that we haven't
tampered with stuff.
In fact, if you do do recall log
info,
and now you're actually helping, and you'll be
a verifier
of our log to make sure stuff doesn't
get tampered with.
Log info. One word. Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. So this is the first time
you hit the log. You now stored stuff
at that length. If you ever hit it
again in, you know, a couple years from
now,
then it'll make sure that nothing in the
log up until now was tampered with. So
you're helping. You're doing your part. For searching,
though, we can do this is kinda what
you might wanna do to look through it
for things with your email address. There's a
search command.
Can search dash dash email. You can search
on a couple different fields. That should work,
hopefully.
And that is just the one? Yep.
Perfect. So
nobody's been stealing your password, you know, before.
Yeah. So that's how all that stuff works.
There's a bunch of cool stuff with time
stamps and everything to also help protect and
limit the blast radius if you do lose
your signatures.
But it starts to get pretty complicated.
Okay. So that was all the three parts
of sigstore. Just the plain keys,
KMS systems, or you can start using transparency
logs and certificate authorities.
Okay. So we've got cosign, which is a
tool for signing and verifying
artifacts,
one of which could be a container image.
We've got rakor,
which allows us to work with the transparency
log, get information over to searches against it.
And those are the two major components of
sigstore.
Yeah. There's the the third one, which is
the one kinda behind the scenes, the one
that actually issues those certificates, that's called Foolsio.
You should never really need to interact with
it yourself. That's just the tools to get
the certificates for you.
We we got a a couple of questions
there if you wanna tackle them, and and
then we can Let's go for it. And
then there's kinda one other thing we'll do
now. We've got recourse set up after these
questions. Sweet.
Is okay. So CPP for life. Is there
any info about what service was used to
help Microsoft or something else to verify the
email address? I'm assuming I added that last
bound.
Yeah. So
that's a that's a tricky one we're trying
to figure out too. We we store that.
Right? We have those three OIDC providers. That's
GitHub, Microsoft, Google. Those are the only three
we support. They're pretty big and trustworthy, we
hope. But we do wanna figure out how
to log that info and make it available
just in case something bad does happen. The
problem there is that the info they give
you back usually has some long number in
there, which is kinda fixed and can be
a privacy concern.
Also, if you change your email address on
Google, that number usually stays the same, and
you can start to peep and start to
do some scary stuff like
correlate things across email addresses. So we've gotta
figure out how to store it and make
it available without leaking people's privacy.
So we store it ourselves for a retention
period just in case something goes wrong to
do some incident response, but we don't publish
that in the logs yet because it's a
little bit scary.
Alright.
We got another question asking.
So is keyless option using hosted
by sigstoreorg
and the transparency log handled by Rawkode?
Yeah. So we run those two services, the
CA and the transparency log kind of as
a public good instance. So the sigstore community
hosts and manages those.
Set up as a transparency log, you don't
really have to trust it. You can audit
it. You can't really do anything bad without
it going on to that log in case
something does happen. But it does require you
to hit these external services. So there's some
other modes you can set up inside of,
like, an organization to host parts of that
yourself so you don't need to be constantly
going outside of your firewall to get certificates
or to
log data to the log. The most part,
it's just hashes, so you're not really leaking
tons of proprietary information in a SHA two
five six hash. But still, sometimes you don't
wanna be even allowing outgoing network connections. You
can run parts of it yourself too.
Sweet. I'm curious. But you did as
a signing episode with Pop on Cloud Native
TV. Right? Was that for this hosted Brazil?
Yeah. So that that was a that was
our root key ceremony, basically. So, yeah, the
full COCA and even the Recore log itself
has to assign a bunch of things to
make the proofs work and everything.
And we need a bunch of our own
keys in order to do that. And so
keys are hard to manage. They're scary. People
lose them. And so what we we did
is we followed the protocol defined by the
update framework or TUF, which is another graduated
CNCF project.
It's not really a code base. You can
kinda just grab and start using. They do
have some libraries and everything, but it's more
of, a framework for managing keys in a,
you know, distributed setup like this.
And so there are five key holders as
part of the sigstore project now, and we
have, like, a rotation setup so people don't
have to do it forever.
And we each have Yuba keys, and it
takes three out of the five to actually,
you know, sign things or delegate new roles
or replace keys and that kind of thing.
So if any one of us loses ours,
the other four can
fix it for them and, you know, sign
a new key. So as long as we
still have three of them at any given
time, we're good. So that was that event
we did. It was the the first one
where we all had to kind of take
them out of the box the first time
and establish that root of trust And now
we can use the update framework to make
changes to and iterate on going forward.
Awesome.
Alright. This is all very, very cool. What
have we what have we got next?
Alright. There's one more thing here. Right? I
talked about the signatures. They're kinda they can
just store basic information about the container, which
is cool. If you sign in a build
system, that's nice.
But what we can actually do is store
more than just the container name. We can
store stuff about how it was built.
So let me get you a quick
command to run.
And this works with our integration in the
Tekton build system, but there's nothing really
about Tekton
that's special here.
We have the Tecton build system generate payloads,
basically, that explain exactly how something got built,
like a container.
So it's not just the container now. It
has the exact commit
that was fetched to do the build, the
exact containers that were using the build steps,
all of that cool stuff. And it writes
it in a payload and stores that in
a transparency log too.
Let me
find the easiest number to send you so
you can do this check quickly.
It's
not working here.
I got a blog post where you could
follow along.
Yeah. Sure.
There's a typo.
Alright. Yeah. So the blog post is here.
It's called the it's a the CD foundation
blog, and the title is called the meta
chain. If you wanna search for that, you
should find it. Of course. Oh. For some
reason, the command is not working. Meta chain
CD
This
one?
Yeah. Verifiable supply chain metadata for Tekton.
Exactly.
So
we did a release of Tecton that was
signed with Tecton itself. That's why it's called
Meta.
And then it stored all of that in
the transparency log. Oh, sorry. That's actually the
wrong one.
There's a more recent one. But I gotta
work it here. I'm gonna send you the
number to grab.
Oh,
sorry. I've I've got it. July 29.
Cool.
So this is the last release we just
did last week. So instead of just signing
the containers that were part of this tech
hunt release, you can see that we signed
these giant they're called attestations.
And this shows all the info about how
the thing was built, and that goes into
the transparency log too.
So if you start there at the top,
if all you have is the container ID
for the tech hunt release, that's the SHA
256 thing, Show you the next text box.
Yeah. So if you if you got that
running, you've got the SHA256
for a container. You can search that in
the transparency log
using that search command. So instead of an
email now, we're just gonna look up everything
we know about that SHA. Mhmm.
We get these entries here, and then you
can download one, and you can see all
the information that's used, all the parameters,
the version information,
the
exact batch script that was used to build
this thing. I'm assuming I could just run
this on my own machine as well. Yeah.
Yeah. I didn't wanna try to read that
UUID out to you.
Alright. So this is everything that we need
to know about this build. Yeah. That's exactly
how it was built. See the parameters that
went into the text on task run. These
are all the strings, the key value pairs,
or the
thing we fetch from in the Kubernetes cluster,
that long bash script. It's native technology is
based on bash and tarballs
and YAML.
The exact container steps that were used, we
had crane running in there. You can see
the digest, all that stuff. So if something
got compromised in any of these things, we
we have all the tools to kinda trace
all the way back.
Cool. So this is all set up. You
just install this in your Tecton cluster, you
just kinda get this out of the box.
Everything gets signed and logged.
Nice. I like that.
I'm curious. Like, this transparency log, you said,
is append only. It's it's gonna continue to
grow. Like, does that mean that the data
lives forever? Will it ever be trimmed? Do
you deprecate or time to live older entries?
Is that impossible because of the Merkle tree?
Yes. So the way people normally do this
is they kind of time bound stuff. If
you look at, like, the Let's Encrypt Transparency
logs, they have a different one every year.
They keep the old ones for some amount
of time.
It's not a huge, huge, huge amount of
data. Right? It's not, you know, petabytes of
data that we've got in here.
So it's it's nothing that's kinda gonna push
the bounds of SQL technologies.
But, yeah, we do need to set up
ways to kind of rotate and cut off
the log
and then start a new fresh one, but
still let you kinda search back through the
historical ones.
Supply chain stuff is a little different because,
yeah, you run code that's, know, maybe a
couple years old. You might probably shouldn't be,
but people do that. So we can't deprecate
things as quickly as you can with certificates
where once they expire, you don't care about
them anymore.
Yeah. It'll grow until we, you know, freeze
it and stick them, publish the archives, that
kind of thing.
Should people ever run their own log?
Yeah. A lot of organizations
do or are trying to figure out how
to or to to run them.
It's not always the best fit. Right?
Mirroring our log and verifying it is great.
That's awesome because we can get kind of
multiple copies of it that are independent around
the world. But a lot of organizations trying
to run them internally
doesn't necessarily make the most sense because the
log only works if you have, you know,
people auditing it and checking you. And if
you're all on the same team, you're kinda
checking yourself, and you're not really getting any
of those benefits. It's easier to just use
a plain database in that in that case
because you do get a bunch of complexity
that only makes sense if you do have
people that are kinda being skeptical and making
sure you're not screwed up.
K. Awesome. Alright. I'll throw two quick questions
at you, and then we'll we'll carry on.
So we got a question saying, is the
Tekton integration through chains or something else?
Yeah. So it's done through the there's a
little sub project called Tekton chains. So to
install next to your Tekton cluster, you just
start getting this stuff signed.
It can store stuff in, you know, any
database you want to. It doesn't necessarily have
to be the transparency logs, so you can
throw it into BigQuery or DynamoDB
or any of those document databases to do
kind of more querying on later.
Right. Is it similar to Intoto? Yeah. So
that format is actually from Intoto.
That's another CNCF project. The Intoto project defines
a bunch of formats for kind of describing
the supply chain step.
If you think of a a build step
as a bunch of inputs came in, did
a bunch of stuff on those inputs, and
then a bunch of outputs came out, you
know, those three things.
And TOTO is a really good set of
formats for describing those things in ways that
you can link back together and check.
Sweet. Thanks for that.
Alright. What what do we what do we
do next?
Good question. I could not get my
cluster and Kiverno and policy engine all set
up. That was kinda what I wanted to
do next. Sure. You can set up verification
there. Yeah. Not quite sure what's going on.
My cluster got all screwed up over the
weekend, and I didn't get it working in
time.
But if you look at the maybe you
could see the docs. I know they're working
on a release that's supposed to go out
any day now to explain how all of
that works.
Maybe we can find the stuff.
But, yeah, basically, you just write a YAML
file with so this should be under k
y v e r n o there, GitHub.
Oh, so this is the okay. So this
is the Kibernal one? Yeah. This is what
I was gonna get set up to show
how you can block deployments unless the signatures
are matched
with a little CRD they have set up
so you can put the public key right
there.
Yeah. It's it's right in the main On
the main one. Cavernote.
Yeah. I don't actually know where the their
docs forward are. I had
a setup a while ago.
It is in the release notes, though. We
should be able to see it if you
click on releases.
Maybe somebody in chat will know where it
is.
Image verification.
So if you scroll down yeah. There we
go with cosign. So,
yeah, if you get this installed and set
up from ahead because I haven't quite done
the release yet, I think that's where I
screwed up. I was installing an actual release
instead of this draft.
Then you can kinda define a new verific
image verification CRD
and put in some public keys, and it'll
block you from deploying.
If you click that Google Doc link, that's
what I was going off of. Ah, okay.
Cool.
Yeah. So this shows what the CRD looks
like.
Install kabrino, and then you just kinda stick
a public key into some YAML.
That's just a normal cosign key, and then
it would block all images that don't have
that set.
I did have this working at one point.
I even made a full GIF.
Okay. So when
I've got cosign running in my CI environment,
sending all my images Yep. We can with
Kivernal installed to a cluster, add a new
cluster policy that monitors your pods
and checks that there's checks the images that
match a certain pattern
assigned by a specific key.
Yeah. And so then you can set it
up to there's the enforce
or alert, you know, failure action. So you
might wanna block it. You might just wanna
send an email to someone and warn them,
I just wanna log it. There's a couple
different setups you can do there, but that
because you can't accidentally you know, there have
been a bunch of kind of typo attacks
where you've fat finger and type the wrong
name of an image from Docker Hub, and
now you're grabbing something from somebody you don't
know because you put two o's in the
MongoDB container instead of one, and people set
up coin mining and all sorts of terrible
stuff like that.
So Okay. A bunch of different reasons you
might wanna do this type of policy. But
if you get that set up in your
CI system, it's all signed, then you know
that your prod environment is locked down to
stuff that came from that CI system.
Yeah. This was
merged twenty five days ago. I'm assuming this
maybe hasn't quite had a release yet. Yeah.
It's r c three now. I saw it
in the draft. So any day now, it'll
it'll come out and I think yeah. I
screwed up and didn't quite get the release
candidate running.
Well, it says that it's released. Right? One
four two?
It's still a draft though if you click
on the Oh, yeah. 14 one's the latest.
So okay.
Alright. So really
soon.
The latest is 141.
Yeah.
Anyway Definitely something cool to play with later.
And I I like this. I wonder, though,
like, this wouldn't technically work with the
keyless approach. Right? Okay. Nope. So, yeah, they
I don't know if we made it into
this version, but you can see some discussion
around it. You can put email or OITC
accounts somewhere too and lock down to that
rather than just the keys.
And I think my little admission controller people
were talking about earlier can do that too
with a config map, or you can put
in keys or email addresses, whatever kind of
combination there you wanna verify against.
Alright. Awesome. Very cool feature. I'm assuming that
I think you mentioned Gatekeeper earlier, so the
OPA projects are probably working on similar support.
I'm assuming Cube Warden
probably gonna have another policy and that works
with all of this. It's nice to see
that support coming from the broader cloud native
ecosystem as well.
Yeah. I've been trying to get it working
in KubeBoard, and I thought it was gonna
be so easy because this is all written
in Go, and you can compile Go to
Wasm, and you can get that running in
KubeBoard.
But the the Go Wasm support isn't quite
there yet, and you can't do a bunch
of stuff you need in in that. So
Yeah. It's soon it's not Kubarden. It's it's
Go and WASM, unfortunately.
So the the spec that we have for
cosign explaining how this works is stable too,
so you could go implement it in something
else like Rust that does compile down to
Wasm a little bit better.
But I was disappointed. I thought it would
just be adding some compiler flags, and then
we'd have support.
Yeah. Just change the target to Wasm and
hope for the best. Right? Exactly.
Yeah. You just can't do reflection,
which turns out is needed for JSON parsing.
So doing any kind of
well, I'm in the Kubernetes ecosystem is tough
because it's all kind of reflection based. Yeah.
I I think you should just jump on
the Rust trend. It's a it's a it's
a fun trend to be on, especially with
the WebAssembly report. It's it's pretty sweet.
Yeah. Alright. And is there anything else you
wanna show, or will we is that a
that is
Yeah. I think that's a that's a good
overview,
especially if you're working with containers. You can
just grab cosign and then start to play
with the rest of the transparency logs and
the CA and all of those features.
So, I mean, that
was all pretty self explanatory. Like, running those
commands, there was nothing too daunting there. It
was all pretty nice, which just shows that
it's a pretty great developer experience.
Is this can I use cosign for
like, it doesn't have to be container images?
Right? I'm thinking of other open source projects
I've got where we release binaries. Can I
sign these binaries and publish to that log?
Yeah. Yeah.
Don't know how we blanked on that. Yeah.
The all the cosign stuff itself on the
GitHub repo is signed with cosign. So instead
of sign container, there's a sign block command
where it just kinda spits out the signature.
It's really easy to do that. The challenge
is, like, how do where do you put
those signatures?
There's no standard great place for it. So
for us, we just put them in, you
know, that GitHub releases page, and you can
check those with cosign too.
Yeah.
The cool part is a lot of things
are moving to the container registries like we
talked about. You know, OPA lets you put
bundles there.
Envoy and Istio now lets you put Wasm
modules into a container registry.
So, yeah, you can sign binaries. You can
sign all sorts of other packages, but it's
kinda cool to see everything moving and converging
on the container registries anyway at the same
time.
The other one, though, I think, you mentioned
in your tweet today to chat about was
the SBOMs, the software building materials and stuff.
So there's a ton of different tools and
formats for generating those and working with those.
They're huge, you know, documents that you've gotta
upload, store, and sign somehow too. So cosign
has some commands for working with those.
And you can upload those. Works the same
as our signatures. There's a just a funny
little naming convention where you just put a
dot s bomb at the end instead of
a dot signature.
And then it looks like an image, so
you can sign that too, and you can
point that at an image and download the
s bombs
for your image and that kind of thing.
Alright.
Okay. I'll ask you one more question. If
anyone in the chat has anything they wanna
ask Dan before we finish up for today,
it on the comments. You've got a couple
of minutes.
In fact, I'll I'll throw two questions at
you then.
So the first one would be, like, do
you see this being something that would be
integrated with a platform like Snyk? They do
a lot of code scanning, dependency scanning, and
it feels like they should be able to
maybe pick up on these signatures and the
s bombs and be able to give us
more details as well. Is that something that
already works or you know is in progress
or
any info there?
Yeah. That's I hadn't thought of it that
way. Yeah. Once the stuff is stored, you
know, things like sneaking, you know, show it
and render it in the UI. Actually, the
CNCF Harbor registry is working on that now,
kinda rendering these and putting little lock green
check marks next to things that are signed
and aren't signed at the registry level.
We didn't we just started working, I think,
last week on kind of the reverse integration,
though, which is how you might store these
sneak or trivia scans in a registry for
a container.
It's a little bit different than something like
an SBOM because they go out of date.
Right? If you just because something had no
vulnerabilities today, it doesn't mean nine months from
now, it has no vulnerabilities.
These things get found over time.
So there's kinda like a
timestamp approach that you would put in there
saying, it had no vulnerabilities today.
And then you might have an admission controller
that says, I wanna only allow stuff to
run that I've checked within the last thirty
days or something like that. So you can
kinda combine those scanners with time stamps and
signatures to make sure that you're constantly checking
them. You don't have to worry about forgetting
an image that's sitting and running in your
cluster.
Cool.
And what's what's coming next then? What's the
the next major deliverables for the project? Yeah.
The next one is really just getting rid
of that experimental. That's scary thing. So there
shouldn't be a huge change in the UX
at all. You'll just you just won't have
to set those flags, and that stuff will
just be turned on and working by default.
So you don't have to use keys if
you don't want to. I mean, that's really
just more making sure we have a playbook
to do if something syncs its way into
that log, and we do have to delete
and move things forward for other reasons.
Couple weeks ago, actually, there was a fun
issue with certificate transparency where a cosmic ray
flipped a bit and screwed up the Merkle
tree. I don't if anybody saw that. Yep.
Yeah. They traced it down. The right data
went into the log, and one bit was
flipped, and it kind of invalidated the whole
Merkle tree.
And so people pieced it together and figured
it all out.
We gotta figure out what to do in
those cases.
Yeah. I'm glad other people are solving those
problems.
Alright. One question from the chat and
a little from pop as well. Hey, pop.
CPP for life is asking,
is there any cosign integration with GoReleaser?
No. Not yet. I don't think so. Nothing
direct. Carlos has been working on a bunch
of our release engineering stuff. Carlos is awesome.
I don't know if he's listening today. Oh,
actually, he's on vacation. But, yeah, GoReleaser has
some scripting modes where you can kind of,
you know, an escape hatch to do other
stuff. So he's got some of those demos
working. But, yeah, it would be awesome to
get some GoReleaser support,
especially if people start storing random binaries in
the GHCR
registries rather than little releases page inside of
GitHub. I think that would be a huge
one for everybody.
Sweet. Kinda Homer style.
Alright. And of course, people, it's open source.
You can all contribute. Go check out the
organization on GitHub at github.com/techstore.
Alright, Dan. Thanks for having me on. That
was awesome. Thank you so much for taking
time out of your day and and kinda
guiding us through
sigstore, cosign, rakor,
and keyless stuff is all very, very cool,
all very exciting, and we can't wait to
see what happens next. So have a a
great day, and I'll hopefully speak to again
soon.
Yeah. Thanks for having me on. Bye. Bye
all.